you're here a lot in los angeles you
know various because of the industry but
you still live in canada is that right
yeah
so that's a strange i have to think that
is an extreme difference between
living in canada and then spending time
in los angeles yeah it's so vastly
different like i when i landed the other
day i'd landed from london and i was
just kind of hanging out there and just
being so chill and when i got here i
went straight to the pool as you do
sat by the pool and there was a woman
across the way who was going
my dad just bought me these fake breasts
and like i really like them and she was
like so serious about it
and everyone was just like yeah for sure
like i think they look really nice
they're really good like what world am i
in right now that's like
yeah so it was a gift it was like a
birthday i don't know i don't know what
the context was it's so crazy no idea
what the context was but it was a very
normal thing for her to be saying that
to this group of people yeah they were
like yeah obviously sure those oh you
got those kind those are the good ones
yeah my dad gets me the other kind yeah
it's so oh it's so weird and so weird no
one's they're not talking about that in
canada are they no they're like i just
put maple syrup on these waffles
that's not true that's not true at all i
love that you're doing this stereotype
i'm making fun of my own people yeah
that's okay and then a mounty peeks his
head in uh yeah he's like yar no he's
not like
they're not pirates yes they're pirates
they are yes there it's all your fault
you grew up in uh regina saskatchewan
yep and uh that you know what's funny is
to say what are you giggling about
that's the name of the town yeah
that's my hometown that's her hometown
regina saskatchewan
show up guys grow up grow up
yeah i like that i'd be telling them
30 seconds to go
your city was voted your town was voted
second safest city in a zombie
apocalypse to get to okay there was
actually an article about this where it
said if you can get to
regina you'll be safe from a zombie
apocalypse what was their reasoning that
of all the places to go in the world
yours was number two it's freezing
freezing cold i would assume that
zombies can't like even operate in those
conditions
you've said this before too candy
zombies freeze we're mostly water so if
it's freezing you're gonna yeah you're
not a sour not a zombie no but
zombies are still mostly water uh from
in my studies i found out most
emotionally water yeah it's stinkier
water than what we're made of but so
you're saying they would freeze they
would just
yeah okay are there other salad and then
you go out and cut their heads off okay
casually yeah yeah at your own leisure
right right whenever you feel like it
yeah no you've got like seven months oh
yeah so you've got seven or eight months
to do it to chop you know i got it off
till the end
[Laughter]
oh boy
but what else makes regina such a great
place to to have a zombie apocalypse
yeah besides that it's cold places are
cold i don't know my friends and i we
actually literally discussed this in a
serious manner on a road trip once we're
like if there's a zombie apocalypse
beeline for the walmart because you've
got everything there you've got guns
you've got food you've got clothing
right josh groban cds
all the josh groban you could possibly
want you need those just throw it to
zombies